so my posts are gonna be all over the place this week
um life is continuing as normal here in Charleston
and I'm gonna be posting some of my regular stuff
but on the back of my mind constantly is what's going on in North Carolina
and how I can help Matt and I are going on a trip this weekend to Utah
like my kids still have school and activities
it's the Jewish New Year this weekend
so life for us is continuing on pretty much as normal
but I've just posted a comprehensive list of places that you can donate
to help the relief efforts for Western North Carolina
on top of that I am starting to collect supplies
me and Matt are planning to go up early next week
grocery stores are already low on stuff
things around Charleston are starting to get low
um I saw Costco and Walmart in Mount Pleasant already out of water
I think everyone's anticipating either another Hurricane
realizing how unprepared we are
and anticipating the longshoreman strike
so if you're local to the Charleston area
make sure that you are prepared for a storm event
if you have anything extra you can donate to bring up to North Carolina
you can message me or
there are lots of neighborhoods that are collecting items right now
that you can donate to as well
things like gas batteries
blankets baby items
so like formula diapers
baby wipes water is a big one
water and gasoline I think
are the biggest ones but honestly
anything that y'all can donate
um I know it doesn't feel like enough
but every little bit is going to help
so along with my regularly scheduled content
I will be posting as many updates as I can about Western North Carolina
from friends and loved ones who I get information from
from other resources from Facebook groups etc
I just heard today actually
a big announcement that I forty is open
I forty East is open from Asheville
and they're saying that there are supplies in Hickory and east of that as well
I forty West is still closed
but the North Carolina dot is saying that it should be reopening soon
and I got that information from North Carolina's weather authority
which is a Facebook group that
I have been receiving updates on the situation in North Carolina
if you wanna follow along
go ahead and check them out as well
it seems to be the best place to get the most up to date
information about the relief efforts